Would you consider having a discussion with Thomas Soul that Sam Dugan Dougan
deal getting?
Probably a,
yeah,
I definitely considered,
I,
I'm thinking hard about reaching out to them.
I have some discussions coming up that you might be interested in.
So,
um,
I'm going to talk on Jocko Willink,
his podcast,
and he was the leader of the Navy seals team in Ramadan and he's quite the tough
character and met him down in San Diego a while back,
a month ago or so.
And that was very interesting.
I have a video already prepared.
That's an interview with [inaudible] out in Herzliya Lee.
Um,
it was done by Skype and need some editing and so that's been a bit delayed.
I interviewed or discussed,
I had a discussion with Nina Paley who was a great animator.
You guys should look her up.
That's Nina Paley.
She animated a lot of the Old Testament and set it to music and I think her
animations are unbelievably beautiful and she has great musical tastes.
They're illegal videos.
Basically.
She's making a knee legal movie.
Um,
but anyways,
I really liked your stuff.
Um,
I also had a discussion with Claire Lehmann who runs [inaudible],
which is a new news magazine online,
which I think has got real promise and we had a good discussion.
And,
um,
let's see,
is that a to habitat?
I think that's the how to,
and you probably know or maybe you don't.
Um,
I just finished a discussion with Camille Paglia and we went down there.
I took a film crew down there to Philadelphia and met her at her university.
And,
uh,
we talked for a couple of hours and that was really interesting.
She's quite the fireball,
that woman and unbelievably verbally fluent and sharp.
And so I finally met someone who can talk more than me and,
and uh,
that's probably good.
So,
but I really enjoyed speaking with her and I think about a hundred thousand
people have watched that now in a day.
So that's pretty good.
So,
uh,
we talked about postmodernism and the malaise that confronts the modern
university and all of those sorts of things.
So Robin Dion says,
do you ever Miss Montreal?
Hey,
I was just in Montreal.
I went there to sub,
saw a band called half moon run,
which are bound.
I would highly recommend they were playing with the Montreal Symphony Orchestra
and I got invited to meet one of the singers and also going out and,
uh,
see the concert,
which was excellent.
And Yeah,
I'd Miss Montreal.
Montreal is a great city for you.
Americans who are listening should go visit Montreal.
Man,
it's a cool place.
And spend a week there in the summer.
It's,
it's a really good city in,
in every way.
So.